danielle casino human beatbox is a role
model for these aspiring young rappers
they long to be as cool as the big guys
we're from Camilla 13 and we're the best
they boast at least they're the actor
beat within the hip-hop scene of midday
you normally the hilly neighborhood
community is in the headlines because of
gang wars cocaine dealers and contract
killings Danielle used to be in a gang
and was involved in numerous robberies
and drug-related crimes for young people
on come una 13 it's a way of life he
explains he decided to get out after the
leader of his gang was shot dead now at
22 Danielle makes a living from graffiti
art he teaches courses and also gets
funding from the local authorities
the children in Kiruna 13 need new idols
daniel says instead of gangsters he'd
like to see them becoming artists or
rappers four years ago he traded in his
gun the spray cans yes una forma de
mostrar el barrio come on I see the
neighborhood as a book that people write
their thoughts and dreams in it okay
sueno but I'll sure what I'm doing is
adding my positive messages to this
gigantic book and I do that in a range
of colors so that others get a different
pictures para que la gente tengo
threatens I see only sunnery smile is
the message he spraying today in big
letters people in this deprived
neighborhood really have much cause to
feel optimistic medellin has come a long
way since it was the battleground of
drug cartels and guerrilla groups in the
1990s however good muna 13 on the edge
of the city is still considered one of
the most dangerous neighborhoods in
Colombia in 2002 the government sent in
the armed forces to free the area from
paramilitary groups Danielle vividly
recalls operation Orion later this ID
thought I'd be one of his works is a
protest against the ruthless tactics of
the army and police
maury Aaron setenta Y dos personas y
tres en 72 people died nosotros with
another 300 missing we believe you can't
beat violence with more violence we see
art and culture is the answer so this is
a form of resistance thank you so much
shovels instead of guns the city
authorities have decided to adopt a new
constructive strategy to the problems
here Medellin has been investing heavily
in its poor neighborhoods and this is
one of the results a 400 meter long
outdoor escalator running up the steep
slope of communal 13 previously
residents had to climb hundreds of steps
to get home from the city center
architect Carlos Escobar heads the urban
planning team in charge of the giant
escalator what makes this transport
infrastructure project so essential he
says is not just improving physical
mobility in his opinion it's about
inclusion the escalator has huge
symbolic value is a little piece a
cambiar el gouna man it changes the
attitude of local residents and their
feeling of being excluded it's important
for them to feel their part of society
solamente una Escalera selected it's not
just the escalator el metro and Metro
projects like the subway the cable cars
the libraries and parks and the new
schools they're all responds to the need
for investment in neglected
neighborhoods version que necesitan CNT
c attendees Franco's la mirada en la
tierra hey there needs to be more
substance than just concrete say the
rapids of community especially
the hip-hop scene offers the teenagers
there an alternative to a career in
crime La Cosa Nostra he owned a dell
arte de local to raleigh's art gives us
a chance to join forces and make
decisions listen a dos palos we have to
use art as a means of creating a
dialogue without dialogue there will
never be an end to the violence sentamos
adi eluga street artist danielle enjoys
his life away from crime and wants to
help more young people sees their chance
see associate elevator you know just
seeing them discuss their graffiti
designs with him is a success in his
eyes costruire una mejor vision una
ocasión baraka his fashion for music and
graffiti probably saved his life says
Danielle dolly cantamos y se lo hace he
wants to spread that message to as many
youngsters as possible and help build a
better future for communal 14oz
condiciones no-nos interesa mabi olesya
solo que Remora